In this video, we're going
to talk about how
to visualize data.
In particular, we're going to
use something called a stem
and leaf plot.
And what's useful about this is
it essentially allows you
to show all of your data and
show a lot of detail about all
of the numbers in your data set,
while at the same time
having a good sense about how
those numbers in your set are
distributed.
Right here, I have
a set of numbers.
And when I just look at this,
it really doesn't make a lot
of sense to me.
It's just a bunch of
numbers to me.
I have no sense are more of
them closer to 20 or 30?
Are more of them closer to 80?
Is their median or their
mode 30 or 40 or 84?
I have no idea, just looking
at this list of numbers.
But using a stem and leaf plot,
hopefully, some of this
will become a little
bit more apparent.
And the idea here is to list the
most significant digit in
each of those numbers
in the stem.
So when we talk about the most
significant digit, these
numbers right here,
they range-- let's
see, we have a 2 here.
That looks like-- we have a 1.
That looks like our
lowest number.
And it goes all the
way up to 84.
It has a bunch of numbers in
between in the teens, in the
twenties, in the thirties,
forties, fifties, sixties.
so on and so forth.
So it looks like the most
significant digit here is the
tens digit.
So let's write it right here.
Let's write our tens digit.
And the tens digit could be a
0, 1, 2, 3, 4-- let me write
this a little bit bigger.
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 or-- let
me scroll down a little
bit-- an 8.
These digits will represent
our stem.
So I'm going to draw this
little line around here.
This is going to be a our
stem right there in the
stem and leaf plot.
For a number like 1, the
tens digit is 0.
You could imagine it as 01.
For a number like 84, the tens
digit is obviously 8.
So what I'm going to do is
rewrite all of these numbers
here using the stem
and leaf plot.
And the technique here, and I'm
just going to show you by
example, let's go through
each of these numbers.
Let's say I want to write 35.
So 35-- let me cross it out.
35, so it has a tens
digit of 3.
I'll put a 5 right here.
That tells me that 35 is
one of my numbers.
Then I have 42.
Cross it out, let me
know I used it.
42, I'm writing the ones
digit as leaves.
You're going to see what
I'm going to do.
Let's see.
38.
Well, I have a 30.
I'm going to write an 8 here.
So I didn't have to
rewrite the 30.
I'm just saying, look, I have
a 35 and I have a 38.
I'm just writing the ones digits
within the three stem,
within the tens place, within
the thirties place, however
you want view it, the
thirties bucket.
Then we have a 57.
We have a 2, which you could
just view as 02.
We have a 2.
We have 24, 27, 36.
We have a 35, a 38,
and a 36, 45, 60.
I think you get the idea,
but just for the sake of
completion, let's finish
all of these.
38, 40, another 40, a 44, a 1,
another 44, a 48-- there's a
lot of things in this forties
bucket-- 48, an 84, a 38, a
20, a 4-- put that right
there, 04-- a 2.
It's getting a little
monotonous, but
let's just finish it.
48, another 48 right
there, a 58, a 3.
Stick it up there.
It's 03.
Then we have a 20, a 6,
a 40, 22, 26, 17.
That's our first number
in the teens bucket.
An 18, a 40-- a lot of things in
the forties-- a 51, 62, 31,
27, 48, 35-- almost done--
27, 37, 58 and 21.
And we have our 21.
And just like that, it was a
little monotonous, but we
essentially just rewrote this
list of numbers down here.
I have every number
represented.
We haven't lost any
information here.
I know every number.
I could go start with this,
and I could tell you every
number that I had in my original
list. I have a 6, I
have a 27, I have a 38, a 35.
So we haven't lost
any information.
But what's neater about this
representation is when the
numbers are written this way, we
actually save ink, because
you don't have to rewrite
the 40 to 45.
You just write the ones digit.
But more importantly, we kind of
understand how the numbers
are distributed, that we have
a bunch of numbers in the
forties and thirties
and twenties.
That's where most of
the numbers are.
We have very few numbers
up in the eighties.
We have no numbers
in the seventies.
We have very few.
We have a lot in the ones, but
still, most of them are
focused in this range
over here.
So this is just one of many,
many, many ways to visualize
data that you will run into
in your mathematical or
statistical futures.
But I just wanted to
expose you to this.